just a little warning so you know this
is gonna be a very frank and open
conversation so if there's anything you
don't want to hear before you see it you
might want to stop now
hi were the Russo brothers we're gonna
talk about the biggest moments in the
MCU I am Iron Man
Favreau really did set the tone for the
Marvel Universe in that film
it is distinctive tone from from other
superhero films in a way that it marries
humor with with spectacle and and you
know it spawned 22000 you and I think it
you know that the the tone that was set
there was like what made us why not want
to become a part of the MCU one day kill
power
[Music]
tony stark's I am Ironman moment is
really the moment that defines
superheroes and the Marvel Universe as
presented to the audience he is the
first know a superhero knees the first
known hero in that universe of course
she seen Captain Marvel you'll know that
the bull she and and the Captain America
came before him but he is the linchpin
what will be the Avengers moving forward
you know I remember you know watching
the original Iron Man movie in the movie
theater it made a huge impression on
both Joe and I and particularly the end
of the film when he says I am Iron Man
because you know up until that moment
you know superhero movies had been so
focused on secret identities and etc for
him to actually just blurt it out at the
end of the movie like that I mean we're
we have a very subversive approach to
how we like to look at storytelling and
and sort of think about pop culture and
that moment was so sort of brilliantly
and unexpected and unexpectedly
subversive that it really excited us it
is one thing to question the official
story and another thing entirely to make
wild accusations or insinuate that I'm a
superhero
I never said you're a superhero didn't
well good because that would be
outlandish and fantastic I I'm just not
the hero type clearly with this laundry
list of character defects all the
mistakes I've made largely public you
know truth is
I am Iron Man now that line while it
made a huge impression on us at the time
you know we the idea of calling back to
that line to end endgame came to its
very late in the progress we're an
editorial in fact the last thing that we
ever shot an Avengers endgame was Robert
Downey saying I am Iron Man and clicking
his fingers we shot that in January of
this year in our final reshoots and
originally he said he didn't say
anything to fan if she smiled and
clicked his fingers it felt empty to us
an editorial and you know Thanos would
say I'm inevitable and then Tony would
smile back and click his fingers and we
just felt like didn't it didn't service
the moment correctly and it didn't
fulfill his journey as a character and
we're seeing that with our editor Jeff
Ford and he said Vanna says I am
inevitable if Tony just responded and I
am Iron Man got the game on she said
let's see this immediately now and ended
up being the last thing poetically it
end up being the last English shot and
and and all credit to Jeff for our
editor he edited every MCU movie we've
done and he's edited several others as
well he's one of the cornerstones
creative cornerstones of the MCU so I
think it's very fitting that he would
have come up with that that line that
sort of pays off the entire series so
well
I could do this all day
[Music]
I can do this all day I think the lion I
could do this all day is really
representative of who cap is as a
character it represents that that that
ethic in him that he he will not quit
until the fight is won and then he will
always stand on the side of right now
it's interesting because that line is
interpreted several different ways and
with different inflections and different
tones throughout the Marvel Universe he
says it in First Avenger you just don't
know when to give up and it's a very
earnest announcement of who he is as a
character he says it in civil war
ironically to Tony at the end of the
film
I could do this all day and then he says
it to himself in the avengers endgame a
younger spunkier version of CAP who
wears spandex says it to an older wiser
version of CAP who doesn't want to hear
it and i think that that that really
illustrates in a really interesting arc
for him as a character if you just study
that line you can see how he how he
moved throughout the Marvel Universe
from a patriot basically to insurgent
and then to you know sort of you know
wise and tough war vet at the at the
very end the elevator fight scene
the first scene that we shot in the
Winter Soldier was the elevator fight
scene which is our very first scene we
shot him in the MCU so it was very
important to see nothing
emotionally metaphorically for a lot of
reasons we felt like the style of
fighting in the elevator was what was
going to make this movie distinctive it
was visceral was hard-hitting it was
aggressive was violent and we felt a
very real world to us
[Music]
and what we're trying to do is take cap
and and pull them into some semblance of
psychological realism and wit that we're
trying to drag you know our corner of
the MCU and that as well and I think
that elevator sequence not only
represents you know mistrust and
subversion but but it also represents a
change in cap forever it would be never
he'll never be the same character again
when he comes out of that elevator you
know one of the great thrills of that
movie is we got to challenge Capps
devotion to Authority and to the to the
country he's served because now when we
were pushing that movie it's like you
know how do you challenge a character
like Captain America you know he's so
strong he's so resolute
he's so single-minded in his purpose and
we thought it was very important to find
a way to undermine that strip away
everything that he was relying on
captain somebody murdered my friend I'm
gonna find out why anyone gets in my way
they're gonna regret it
anyone
understood so the this Revit this moment
of Revelation when he realizes that he
can't trust the team that he's serving
that the authorities that he's serving
happens in but in the middle of the
movie in an elevator when he's in the
Triskelion he's just finished talking to
Robert Redford
he's just lied to a superior presumably
for the first time in his life that's
not something Captain America would
normally do but he's getting a little
nervous about what's happening and he
doesn't know quite how to react or who
to trust then he gets in an elevator
after that meeting and he realizes in
that elevator that he's surrounded by
not by allies that he believed as he
previously believed but by enemies and
it's it's a huge turning point in
Captain America's arc and I think in the
entire MCU where cap realizes that he's
alone and I think that's a real
important marker on his journey which
came which you know goes from sort of a
dutiful selfless servant to an actual
eyes Din dividual at that moment he
realizes he's alone in that elevator and
he has to fight his way out and that's
the beginning of his road to to Peggy
Carter at the end events a fulcrum shift
for the entire MCU from phase 1 to phase
2 think we're you know it's it's they're
going down the rabbit hole it's starting
to deconstruct itself and everything is
not as simple as it appears and it takes
us on a journey all the way to the end
of endgame
there was no doubt we're being self
referential with the hail Hydra moment
and the elevator and end game where were
cap leans in and says hail Hydra but
also it's just a it's it's a way to
symbolize how he has changed as a
character you know that that he no
longer needs to punch his way out of an
elevator that you know the efficiency is
critical for him in this moment and he
is his efficiency even though he could
have won the other way as well and I
think that I think that that's fun for
the audience to see the growth in him as
a character it's it's not only
referential to the comic current comic
run but it's its referential to who he
is it just speaks to how far he's come
spider-man gets introduced in the games
we knew we're doing a build-up to
spider-man he was my favorite character
growing up you know we fought really
hard to get him in that movie it's an
unprecedented deal done between Disney
and Sony to get our hands on spider-man
for civil war yeah it was kind of my
rule a lot to make that deal happen yeah
but we were relentless that we needed
him for the movie and as a great
producers do he obliged and made it
happen and so then we knew we needed an
incredible introduction for the
character and and you know it starts
with a verbal Tia from Downey and a
smile and then it cut to a title card
he says Queen I think that that really
afraid one who knows the character was a
jolt of excitement in the theater
there's a needle drop on the card and
then you know an introduction into the
first you know teenage actor to actually
play spider-man
Oh mr. Parker um what what are you hey
I'm Peter Tom Holland was an actor that
we fought very hard for to play the part
we wanted to make sure that we had a
really boyish you know actor in that
role because that's what I remembered
that I loved about the character what I
identified with and also creates
diversification in the Marvel Universe
just in terms of Heroes is there's all
the heroes there's younger heroes and
younger heroes have different you know
issues that they're dealing with and
will have a different perspective and
problems as they arise and you know one
of the I think one of our favorite
directing moments from any of the Marvel
films was that first scene where Tony
Stark shows up to recruit Peter Parker
and Peter's very small bedroom
and the the way that Downey jumped in
and helped Tom Holland with his blocking
in that scene we just marveled at Robert
and we're like gosh she's creating a
star-making performance through blocking
with Tom so your this spider Ling
crime-fighting spider your spider boy my
spider-man not in that onesie or not
it's not a onesie leave this I was
actually having a really good day today
you know start didn't miss my train this
perfectly good DVD player was just
sitting there and how did you protest
nailed it
who else knows anybody nobody I mean the
best gift you can give to an actor's
that put them in a scene with Robert
Downey jr. and you know nobody's gonna
bring out more out of you because he's
such an amazing actor and he did it was
it was it to see him work with Tom in
that scene and really make sure that we
were maximizing everything we were
pulling everything out of Tom that we
possibly could Downey was worked very
hard in that scene and it was always
always grateful to him for that look
when you can do the things that I can
but you don't
and then the bad things happen
they happen because either
so you want to look out for the little
guy you want to do your part make the
world a better place on that right yeah
yeah yeah just looking after we weren't
looking at the other films for
inspiration we're looking at the comic
books exactly we wasn't even a very
truthful to him as a teenager that was
most important to us in this iteration
of the character is to really run at on
a stylistic level out a casting level
etc this idea that this is a kid a real
kid in New York City and we that fed the
design of his apartment certainly
there's obviously the casting of Tom
first and foremost but yeah we're really
looking on a detail level how do we how
do we bring the that everyday teenager
experience into the equation for that
character it spoke to me when I was 10
and I read spider-man comics was that
you know Peter Parker was Peter Pan type
characters boy genius who suddenly had
an incredible about responsibility
thrust on him and and through very
tragic circumstances and it felt it felt
both
emotional and tragic and and fun all
wrapped up into one and and I didn't
know how to process it as a kid and
sometimes you know the books would make
me really sad and sometimes the books
would make me laugh but they always had
this sort of Shakespearean element and
he was just sort of a you know clown
that moved through the world and brought
mirth everywhere he went so that was
what was so important to us is that we
add that element to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and and that's what we were
chasing that's a good kind
yeah we did have a debate about
synthetic versus organic who think you
know ultimately you know we just felt
like it was more interesting to to go
with synthetic you know that that was
part of his brain and it's just you know
brain as part of his power
Peter part I think that's really what
would total it for us is we you know
again when you're introducing spider-man
it's not a standalone movie he's a small
part of an ensemble so we don't have a
lot of screen time to tell his story and
I think leaning on the synthetic choice
for for his webbing was just a way for
us to help pull out his intellect in
some small ways in this limited amount
of screen time that we have you know
what I think is really cool this wedding
tensile strength is off the charts what
manufactured that I did his actual
reveal and Civil War his costumed reveal
is on the tarmac and
when Tony calls for underoos and again
we like doing little you know little
teases or lead ups to characters and
everybody knows that that means
immediately and then a shot in a certain
way where there's a shadow and a web and
he's flared in the Sun and he lands and
you know and he is the first thing that
he's done in costume is steel cap shield
from him and a curse is an iconic moment
[Music]
in a costume upgrade that Tony Stark
provided for him by the way yeah and
then we thought it was very funny that
you know you're injecting this kid into
a very tense situation but he has no
loyalties one way or the other I mean
he's just there to do what Tony's asking
him to do and and he over talks a little
bit and Tony has to tell him to shut up
and respect the situation yeah thanks
well I could have stopped the landing a
little better it's just a new suit well
it's nothing mr. stark it's perfect
thank you yeah we don't really need to
start a conversation okay Kat captain
big fan spider-man yeah we'll talk about
it later
just everyone good job but we wanted a
very auspicious entry for for spider-man
and something that spoke to like this is
a game changer in the MCU and I think
that was the best thing that we could
come up with this idea of stripping cap
shield from them which is very hard to
do Captain America can lift you on there
well when we saw that moment in age of
Ultron where they're all trying to pick
up the hammer and cap seems to move it
and ever so yeah in a way where you're
not quite sure did I see that did I not
see that did he move it and not really
not one Thor Thor Thor is also not sure
yeah I kept that there's a real moment
of trepidation on the part of Thor but I
think for us like everybody who saw that
moment you just can't forget it and you
just you you you want to go back there
on a story telling ignites your
imagination well cap I don't think cap
was interested in embarrassing Thor yeah
or but it was undermining is what's
great about is this is self bolita in
anyway because Thor is already a
character who struggles with self belief
but he didn't know the cap didn't know
until he tried that he can actually move
it so it's it's very fun to see him
reverse himself at a millisecond like
that fortunately I remember you know
just sitting around the writing room
with Markus and McFeely I can't remember
how it came up but the they might have
been Kevin's bench it might it yeah it
might have been Kevin Feige snitched
that we sort of revisit that concept and
pull it pull it forward to fruition that
was also you know we'll admit that we
snuck into a screening an opening night
and Westwood The Village Theatre and the
moment where cap caught the hammer the
way that the audience responded made six
and a half years of very hard work well
worth it
it's nap so the snap is a it's just part
of our philosophy of the way that we
look at popular movies is that they are
the intention of making a movie like
this of the scale is to you know reach a
global audience with the film that's why
they're called popular movies and and
you want to engage them on a very
visceral level because this generation
is about global conversation and you
know social media is a driver for pop
culture and say we like to make really
disruptive choices and our storytelling
that get people talking and and and
invite them into the conversation we
grew up film geeks and spent our entire
childhood talking about movies and
arguing about our favorite characters
and talking about our favorite moments
and walking out of Star Wars or Empire
Strikes Back Return of the Jedi and
doing the same things that are done
today but just within our little group
of friends now you can have a friend in
India and Japan and the UK that you
talked to online about the same things
and so we're trying to give that same
experience back that made us so happy
when we were kids and we're trying to
give that those kinds of stories to the
world and and we can do that by making
surprising and aggressive choices that
connect them on an emotional level and
and get them talking about
and certainly that of snapping his
fingers and winning at the end of that
movie was going to generate a discussion
we think very specifically about each of
each of the characters in every
narrative that we do and infinity war we
were just thinking about where does the
character begin where do they end we
knew we were her in infinity war we were
hurling toward a final ending in endgame
so infinity war that a lot of the
narratives in infinity where we were
about how did we want to set ourselves
up for the story that we wanted to tell
an end game
so our process of deciding who sort of
was flipped away by Thanos and who
wasn't was based upon where we wanted to
go with the storytelling an end game and
it was very specific to that I don't
feel so good you're all right I don't
want to know want to go
[Music]
we knew that in in in wrapping up the
story in Avengers endgame we were mostly
trying to close the narratives of the
original Avengers
so those characters were preserved so
that they could their their final acts
could be played out in endgame the
guardians of the galaxy becomes the
guardians of the galaxy well certainly
at the end of guardians when they truly
become a family and I think it's maybe a
good sacrifice at the end of the movie
out that would certainly qualify because
the guardians are a whole different tone
and a different you know sub set of
characters that you know can can
intermingle with and crash into you know
the the original trajectory of the
Marvel Universe I think it shook things
up in a way it was spectacular and it
hasn't been the same sense and certainly
infinity war and endgame wouldn't be
what the air without the presence of the
guardians
[Music]
Oh mortal ah said it yourself [ __ ] were
the guardians of the galaxy
so those was just a few of our favorite
moments in the MCU I know there there
are many more that we have and I'm sure
that you have so if you want to comment
below about what those are hopefully we
can continue this conversation